Nos dicen: "El punto A está en (-1,4) y el punto
C está en (4,-6). Encuentra las coordenadas del
punto B sobre el segmento AC, tal que la razón
de AB a AC sea 3 : 5". Pausa el video e inténtalo
por tu cuenta. Bien, trabajemos juntos, y
para ayudarnos a visualizar este problema,
vamos a graficar estos puntos. Primero grafiquemos
el punto A, el cual se encuentra en -1,4,
así que tenemos a -1,4: 1, 2, 3, 4, este de aquí
es el punto A. Y ahora pensemos en el punto C que
está en 4,-6, entonces: 1, 2, 3, 4, -6: -1, -2,
-3, -4, -5, -6, justo así. Ahora podemos trazar el
segmento AC, el segmento AC se va a ver justo así,
y además nos dicen que la razón de la distancia AB
a la de AC es de 3 : 5, u otra forma de pensarlo
es que B estará a 3/5 del camino de A a C. Ahora,
la forma en la que me gustaría pensar esto
es que para estar a 3/5 del camino de A a C,
tenemos que estar a 3/5 del camino en la dirección
x, y al mismo tiempo estar a 3/5 del camino en
la dirección y. Así que pensemos primero en
la dirección x. Vamos de -1 a 4, es decir,
vamos de este punto a este punto, nuestro
cambio en x es de 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, por lo tanto,
si queremos ir a 3/5 de esta distancia, que es de
cinco unidades, entonces 3/5 de esto es sólo 3:
aquí es donde tendremos la coordenada x de B.
Ahora, busquemos la coordenada y. Para ir de
A a C pasamos de 4 a -6, entonces bajamos 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 unidades, por lo tanto,
3/5 de 10 es 6, la coordenada y de B será 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6 unidades hacia abajo. De esta forma
fuimos capaces de obtener las coordenadas x y
y del punto B que estará justo aquí. Entonces
podemos ver directamente esto y decir B tendrá
como coordenadas 2,-2, que obtuvimos gracias
al papel cuadriculado. Otra forma de hacerlo de
manera algebraica es la siguiente: las coordenadas
de B serán, bueno, primero empezaremos con las
coordenadas de A, que son -1,4, y nos moveremos
3/5 a lo largo de este camino en cada una de las
direcciones hasta C; entonces esto será + 3/5
por, ¿y cuánto nos desplazamos en dirección x?
Bueno, en la dirección x, para ir de A a C, nos
movemos de -1 a 4, entonces la distancia es 4
- - 1, que claramente es 5; mientras que en la
dirección y tenemos primero la coordenada y de A,
y a esto le sumaremos 3/5 de la distancia que nos
movimos en dirección y, si vamos de 4 a menos 6,
entonces pondremos -6 -4, lo cual es -10. Por lo
tanto, las coordenadas de B serán: la coordenada
x será -1 + 3/5 de 5 que es igual a 3, entonces
-1 + 3; mientras que la coordenada y será 4 + 3/5
de -10, (3/5) -10 es -6, entonces tenemos 4 + -6.
Esto nos dará, en la coordenada x tenemos: -1 +
3, lo cual es 2, coma, y en la coordenada y tendremos
4 - 6, lo cual es -2, 2,-2. Y hemos acabado,
esto es exactamente lo que obtuvimos por aquí.